most people have a sibling in fact
children in the us today are more likely
to grow up with a brother or sister than
with a father
now while a lot of social scientists
research the impact of schools and
parenting little attention is given to a
relationship that might be even more
consequential
so what do we know about siblings birth
order and why children from one family
grow up to have very different
personalities
let's start with our analysis of the
tragic story of the two most famous
brothers in western history
[Music]
once upon a time there was a boy named
kane who received all the love and
attention from both of his parents
growing up the boy knew only one world
and he himself was at its center
everyone around him cared only for him
and nothing else
all that changed when his mother gave
birth to abel
cain should have understood that his
parents attention now had to be divided
between him and his brother
this was a revelation he wasn't able to
accept and he became increasingly
jealous and sometimes even violent
against his little brother
kane as the firstborn naturally looked
up to his father as his role model
following convention the father himself
raised the boy with certain expectations
it was therefore especially painful for
cain to see that his father now cared so
much for his younger brother
abel naturally looked up to his brother
for guidance things were not easy for
him either but unlike cain abel knew no
different
as the boys grew up kane gained a strong
sense of responsibility and following
tradition took over the family farm
abel who was free from any obligation
chose to become a shepherd
kane envied his younger brother's
autonomy because life as a farmer became
increasingly difficult
and on the day that the brothers were to
make a gift to their father kane only
brought a few bundles of dry grass
abel who did well for himself brought an
entire lamb
when the father thanked abel for his
generosity cain felt a deep shame
overnight his shame turned to hatred of
monstrous proportions and the next day
he killed his own brother
the first big contribution to the field
of sibling research came from the
austrian psychiatrist alfred adler and
his theory of individual psychology
adler believed that the main motive of
human behavior is our desire for power
partly in compensation for our feeling
of inferiority
hence sibling dynamics play a central
role in family life and personality
development as we grow up
adler argued that children who grow up
in the same family experience the family
differently in particular sibling
rivalry over family resources influences
the development of personality
as a means of reducing competition
siblings differentiate develop different
qualities and choose different interests
when siblings don't find their niches
their relationship can suffer
the kellogg brothers hated each other
and fought in court over who invented
cornflakes the darceless competed in
business
after one started adidas the other
founded puma but many siblings love each
other more than anything
so what do we know about siblings in
general
here are six things science suggests to
be true
first born and single children look up
to their father or mother as role models
the gap in mental and physical
development between them and their
parents may be the reason that they have
on average a higher iq
parents tend to give their firstborn
more attention and often set higher
expectations
if they can't live up to those
expectations they may feel inferior but
on average they seem to benefit from
their position
[Music]
younger siblings model their development
after their big brothers or sisters they
have a smaller developmental gap to
overcome they may also feel that they
have less to prove but as a result of a
lack of parental attention they develop
social anxiety more often
[Music]
on average relationships between
brothers are more conflicted
relationships between sisters are more
intimate
siblings spend more time together than
they spend with their parents younger
siblings even twice as much
children with siblings are physically
more active and less often obese they
are often happier too
some studies suggest that they develop
social skills faster than children from
only child families but the research is
inconclusive
sibling attachment seems to be a strong
predictor of well-being sometimes more
important than paternal attachment this
also means that if one is bullying the
other it can affect them for life
one swedish study of people aged 80
years found that while closeness to
friends did little for total life
satisfaction feeling close with a
sibling did a lot
for those of you struggling with a
difficult sibling adler had the
following advice
a simple rule in dealing with those who
are hard to get along with is to
remember that this person is striving to
assert his superiority and you must deal
with him from that point of view
[Music]
this and all other sprouts videos are
licensed under creative commons that
means teachers from all around the world
can use them in classrooms online
courses or to start projects and today
thousands already do to learn how it
works and download this video without
ads or background music check out our
website or read the description below
if you want to support our mission and
help change education visit our patreon
that's patreon.com
sprouts